well hi everyone can everybody hear me
fine yeah fethard yep yep okay let me
know if you can't hear me and I'll try
to stick out more okay so on to start
off I'd like to actually thank the
organizers of the paper school of made
up for doing such amazing things and
continuing this really fun event papers
will love is my favorite meet up so it's
an honor and pleasure to be actually
speaking here about the things I'm
passionate about so thank you they did
not pay me but um okay so um let's get
started so you may be wondering who I am
I work on searching for structural to
Sean mentioned i work on the scheduling
and indexing of the search that's during
day time and then I have a very curious
person so have a lot of different
hobbies I like to my career she drives
me to Barney hi business skills so i
actually do Oh painting in the evenings
and archery and as usual mentioned loool
which is the graph algorithms
and visualization library written
enclosure for closure so I'm working on
that and active maintain and contributor
and actually arrested is what brought
all of us here today instead of taking a
walk in such a beautiful neck which
you're learning about VMs and trying to
expand our knowledge so welcome one of
my biggest passions is compilers if
you've talked to me before I probably
talk to you a lot about compilers about
co compiler technologies and the picture
you see here is actually of my favorite
book it's called advanced compiler
designing a complementation by much
thing so if you ever get curious about
compel optimizations i highly recommend
it it's really really interesting so
today the paper is related to one of my
biggest passions it's about interpreters
compilers virtual machines and the paper
is called 1pm to rule them all you may
be wondering why is it called up fat
it's about one particular game
technology but why is it called one game
to rule them all so the paper in the
related work section actually discusses
that they have been in agreement
in academia that when you build a
virtual machine for a particular
paradigm of the languages friends back
object-oriented virtual machine better
virtue mission that has in mind
object-oriented languages it's very hard
to build other languages and have them
be high performance on the same p.m. so
this paper tries to come up with
techniques and approaches to bridge the
gap performance gap and actually make it
work for any of the languages in Maine
Yoga paradise still let's see how they
did that quick overview if we're going
to talk about today so first we will
introduce the concept intrapreneurs
compiler just a tank and fowler and
virtual machine then we will talk about
the truffle braille they have a coupled
and accept the core of the paper and how
they interact then we will talk about no
specialization which is the technique
that truffled rail users to make it work
to make it be high performance for any
of the language implementations and the
last we talked about the current state
of affairs in the trap on rail of world
this is your chance to brag so let's
take a show of hands who here is
familiar with the concept of
interpreters great compilers event
virtual machines very nice um who wrote
it mature brunette Oh compiler virtual
machine care
excellent okay very nice who actually
designed the language or attempted to
design a language very very cool and
something we're gonna have a lot of fun
here read the paper Wow and who played
with truffle rail hopefully by the end
of it you'll be stuck stanwood you all
right so let's get started so it's a lot
of you are very familiar with what it
interprets a Kampala shower but to make
sure that we're all the same page we're
going to talk about what they are and
what's common and different about them
but it serves me talking i'll let this
video tell me about it
when you land in the world of computers
with their strange convoluted machine
language it's a bit like landing on
another planet whose inhabitants speak
and equally strange convoluted alien
language getting a mechanic on planet
gobbledygook to repair your spaceship
would present the same sort of problem
that you have when you want to get a
computer to do something everything you
say has to be translated and you have a
choice between two different sorts of
translator one of them is called an
interpreter and the other is called a
compiler let's suppose that you've
previously written out your list of
instructions for the repair of your
spaceship and suppose that you choose
the interpreter to do the translating he
reads your first instruction open lid of
rocket engine translates this and the
gobbledygook and immediately passes it
on to the mechanic who execute the
instruction then the interpreter reads
your second instruction remove spark
plug translates this in the gobbledygook
and passes it on to the mechanic who
executes sit and so on and so forth now
notice how the interpreter works he
stays with you all the time and he
translates each of your instructions
immediately one by one this is a rather
slow process because the mechanic has to
wait while each instruction is being
translated but on the other hand it does
give you a chance to correct your
mistakes as you go along if the mechanic
removes the wrong spark plug for
instance you'll see this happen right
away and you'll be able to change your
instruction accordingly compare this
with the way the second sort of
translator the compiler goes about his
work he takes your complete list of
instructions and without further ado
translates the whole lot straight into
gobbledygook he then hands them back to
you and goes away leaving you all on
your
all this has taken some time but from
now on things will go very fast you hand
the complete list of gobbledygook to the
mechanic and he executes them all in one
go bang bang bang there's no waiting
about this time but there's one
disadvantage to this of course if there
was a mistake in your instructions it's
too late now this analogy comes very
close to the way the interpreter and
compiler translator programs actually
work with computers an interpreter runs
slowly starts right away and let you see
how things are going whereas a compiler
takes extra preparation time before your
program can run but then lets it run
very quickly and efficiently to help you
remember the difference between an
interpreter and a compiler look at the
words themselves inter means between the
interpreter is always between your
program and the computer and it
translates line by line to compile on
the other hand means to pile together a
compiler piles together your entire
program and translates the whole thing
all at once which one you use on planet
gobbledygook is entirely up to you
alright now that we know how
interpreters and compilers work let's
talk about them on examples and I
computer froze
all right okay okay so um what we see on
this edge is the abstract syntax tree is
everyone familiar with that what we'll
get started so supposed to have a
function expression which is two times a
lot of Mustangs their way we express
that in an aspect it since extreme form
is two x 11 under some bad yeah thanks
so what they encounter will produce to
you is something like multiply 2 and 11
and store that in a temporary variable
the reason we want to store them in
temporary variables because we want to
use the result of multiplication later
on so then we so we walk up the tree now
super visited a on multiplication know
now we want the tree now we need to load
x the reason we would load X is that
this is this fellow came from elsewhere
in Lake program and if it's a user input
so we need to access the value of
variable X and now what we're going to
do is we're going to add turn one and
ten to
and produce the result for those of you
familiar this looks more like
instruction but I'm avoiding the three
argument instructions up just to make
sure we are on the same page and it's
all too confusing so in shrubbery will
produce this every time I get visit to
those where the compiler will walk there
abstract syntax tree generate to you the
program produce this instructions how it
works are there any questions on this at
the moment okay and feel free to
interrupt me if you have any questions
or just raise your hand and we'll make
sure to address them as we go so now JIT
compilers on which are sent for
just-in-time compilers the way I see
them is that they are interpreter
combined with a compiler so first Jacob
polish starts out an interpreter boat
and runs the program and it tries to
detect is there any code paths that it
executes more than once and it defines
some threshold suppose 10 times and if
it executes function more than 10 times
then we will compile the function and
then run the compiled version of it on
the next execution so first they just
attack your fellow runs an interpreter
mode and then pull the hot pass for the
code paths that run more more frequently
it will compile them to be around faster
the name comes from just in time so as
it detects that they could path is
running being run very frequently it
will compare it just in time for
execution are there any questions about
this all right let's talk about virtual
machines so in a plus in AC program
world in a sea world what we have is
really write a program so this is a
father can also everybody see my
writings okay so we will compiler and I
will produce machine instructions so
this would be your x86 instructions now
with the virtual machines if we do is
instead of compiling directed to machine
instructions will take the program and
then we'll compile to bytecode
and then that the bike coat the virtual
mission will interpret by codes to
measure instructions
so what why you should we use this level
of indirection abutting first by code
into machine instruction isn't the whole
goal is to eventually compile our source
code C machine instructions well there
are two advantages of doing it this way
one of them is that you are able to put
the same program you would target any
hardware so the same java program that
you read is able to run in your laptop
on your desktop on your mobile phone the
other advantage is that it's easier to
optimize bytecode so you may refer to
the word Olivia the low-level virtual
machine yeah so it's much harder to
actually optimize machine instructions
and there are many reasons some of them
being that the hard way we have looked a
number of registers who have limited
number of memory so when we compile code
we have to work around those constraints
for us when we compared to bytecode
barcode assumes i love it the number of
races alerted memory and we can do much
more sophisticated optimizations before
we compile it before we interpret it to
machine instructions so this allows us
to do many powerful optimizations okay
so are we good on virtual machines and
where to stand in the ho ching okay
so now let's talk about truffle and
Grail which make up the core of the
paper so truffle is a language
implementation framework so to break it
down framework means API so it provides
to some functions that we have to
implement in order to get the
functionality that chocolatier has to
offer language implementation sense for
language design if you have a new idea
for the language you have and you
implement it using the truffle API then
you'll be able to have an implementation
of your language and rail via is an
extension to hotspot vm but it exposes
help advance with your nose so try so
creo vm is an implementation of truffle
api that uses your languages
implementation composite using grill vm
ok so where does each of them fit so
truffle is for reading interpreter for
your abstract syntax tree and the grill
is that gives you jit compiler for free
as the language design you don't
actually need to know how gray liam
works how to make it work all you need
to know is how to implement your
language using truffle api and that's it
so the puter of that is if you're really
into type system and you came up with a
beautiful way to represent type system
or you'll figure out a beautiful way to
represent complex computations or you
came up with an interesting syntax and
you want to try that out this allows you
to not get work done by cogeneration or
compiler optimizations to get much
performance out of your
you language but instead focus on the
design parts of the language so you can
get the started with writing programs in
your new language as quickly as possible
and i iterate on it without having it be
too slow so how does truffle and Grail
achieve that well I choose that with
several different techniques but in my
opinion and most important one is no
specialization so let's look at what it
does for now you ignore the right hand
side with a second arrow we'll talk
about it so you're cool I will program
that we had the two times eleven plus X
so actually the abstract syntax tree
that we have written in service looks
very similar to the one we have on the
side so we have our
look so first let's look at the new
transition so the before we start
evaluating our paragraph we don't know
the types of notes that we operating I'm
gonna know the types of our inputs we
don't know anything about it so it's
uninitialized all the nodes are of an
initial attack and we see the no
transition this is just an example so
for multiplication for instance you may
be operating on integers doubles maybe
strings if you define multiplication as
a way to concatenate strings suppose and
the generic way to do multiplication I
name into your objects so now you can go
from uninitialized 2 into 2 double
generic or string and you if you own
flow the interview you could actually go
to add a double or generic
implementation so at this point turn a
log on are both integers so now the
multiplication actually is done on
interested types to expect integer as
our return type and we expect that the
multiplication is on is integer
multiplication so what we can do is we
can actually swap out those notes and
specialized them to be of integer type
so now as we evaluate the program
caps and because trifle assumes
implementation in Java it will probably
be something it will probably look
something like that so it would be like
public and multiply its and it takes two
integers into x into x and then returns
the result of multiplying accident ok
great and now we'll have a profiling
feedback in place for us so we'll have a
counter that sounds whether we were
seeded the threshold and when we do
exceed the threshold the threshold for
being how many times we've got executed
with input types being integers once we
exceed that we will decide that we're
probably the stable state we will
speculate on that the user will not give
us any other input by the integers so
now we can do partial valuation which is
on me on the right hand side so on high
level the way you can think about
partial evaluation is for instance on
this example we have two times 11 plus X
so really what the program is is 22 plus
X so what we doing here to those of you
familiar is constant folding and custom
folder they just a special
case of partial evaluation so we don't
know what access we have to get that at
one time but we can do something about
other inputs that we know so our
interpreters that does know
specialization imagine if it didn't have
specialization it would behave just like
any other jit compiler now because it
does specialize on our language and our
input but we can do is we could compel
that part of the interpreter away so if
from the perspective of the heart body
and gravy m we have our application
codec the source code in the new
language and we have an interpreter code
that's running interpreting and does the
nose facilitation we know what the
interpreter so we can compile that that
is partially evaluated doesn't make
sense to everybody for the origins of it
so now have a compile code we're running
were happy in a very much faster but
what happens if instead of getting here
11 we actually get 0.1 house where
oh this was just a variable so remember
get is so what will get is will get a
double and we can no longer use our
integer multiplication the assumption
that we may they will be operating on
integers only so what we have to do is
we have to be optimized so we're full
back to interpreter will fold back to
our abstract seems extreme now instead
of having integer on the right-hand
believe we're going to have is double
and now with a form of multiplication on
doubles so there will be something like
for like we expected a return type will
be double and then multiply doubles
double X f of wine
and then you get the idea
right so so suppose we had this tree and
new still 11 so really um what we worry
about here is this nut right what does
wood type of input does the smell
operator on integers before right so
we'll specialized this loud these coming
is just an example like particular
example of input but it could be other
arguments coming from elsewhere oh
alright so now went back to it beans
open one obviously we can perform
integer multiplication on a double an
integer correctness is really important
to us so we will sorry yes i learned
what is this clicker by then okay so now
we will have our double now we will
continue right now program with the
assumption that it will be double
multiplication and when we exceed our
threshold for sunday a lot of time we
decided it's actually the multiplying
doubles who do is will agree that we
received we are in a steady state and
rig impalas again using partial
evaluation but now with a double
multiplication as the type of the note
yep
a good question i'm actually going to
cover that in just a moment um so but if
i don't answer a question let me know so
yes so actually a good question add that
leads me to it suppose you had a
function that is
suppose you had a function fool it will
have some dynamic types and it does
something like a plus B now we have
three call sides s is equal to 4 12 why
it gives us input doubles and a cosine Z
we give it strength so the hello w so as
we learn in the abstract syntax tree in
the interpreter do only be one tree for
food so as the three different cause I'd
called different types of inputs but
we're going to have is there going to be
pushing each other's profile and
feedback and in the end we'll end up
with generic implementation because if
you recorded the transitions will go
from integer here to double and then
we'll get the string so just go to the
generic implementation which defeats the
whole purpose of doing no specialization
so instead what we're going to do is
we're going to do use the technical
trick floating so for each cosine we're
going to clone the tree after still
extreme for the function foo and we're
going to insert that there now as long
as at this course and we keep coming
over the integers will specialize with
integer addition and in this Co side
will specialize for
I edition and this cosine was
specialized with extreme edition if you
go for cleaning tree cloning yeah
cloning of the trickiest yes so that's a
straight up but the advantages would get
to use action verbs specialization and
produced up to myself yes sorry
he could say that yeah yeah definitely
um this is
Oh
because there's a whole range of from
the magnetized to showing type languages
so
but
a fancy term for lining in this case
mining the reason after Chloe has been
your ex in fact it belongs to a function
that mention your call sites is a first
offline
oh so it will potentially become in like
the functional potentially country line
later but it's still going to be cold
function until it gets optimized if you
can call them whatever reasons so you
can come to specialized for call site
where you can also clone specialized for
our code paths at a common call sign or
except for its energy code path it will
be yeah I need my a loop where it goes
there juco Pat regularly by specialized
it twice do you make two columns one for
each and then later it will be in line
if it's been cold for for long enough or
if the compiler decides to do global
optimization inaccessible yes going
there threshold for cloning or doesn't
want as soon as it sees different values
so I believe that's actually something
you can do with truffle API you can
determine yourself yeah
so I don't think so if I understand your
question correctly you assume they may
be a cost dispatch because now you have
to call elsewhere oh so this shouldn't
be any extra cost to dispatch because
you're just cloning it over you still be
calling that function if you even if you
didn't do true clothing so this allows
you to do is specialized better it's
burning on the cosine any other
questions yeah yeah that's actually
certainly think so you have to define
how you the most specialized on the note
all the different
gsl that makes it look pretty easy it
seems like the down dag is at these and
the simple temples exclusively derive
for you yeah so actually so you use
javis annotations to do it which is you
know makes it a very seamless little
domain specific language to do that and
the interesting thing that they do is
they use exceptions for control flow for
non local control flow so for instance
for integers if they overflow then they
know they need to be doing operations on
double so they'll throw an exception and
a catch that but if you describe that as
different functions and in function that
specializes in double just catches the
arithmetic flow exception and continues
on yeah
so you as a language designer only now
what makes sense in your language so you
have to do all day no specialization
itself into finally it's been a leader
by the assistance in like profiling and
like actually maintaining it like
Providence of like where data comes from
it's doing all the bookkeeping for you
but you actually have to specify the
optimizations feeling okay would I hear
the question sir oh yes sir god yeah I'm
not from here is a compiler technology
so I just want to clarify here so let's
say this is a JavaScript the expression
this one yes mistress these are
JavaScript i implement interrupts our so
what we compile is I also how I how your
compiler stuff yes was there so this is
version gonna come pirate okay so if
you're cold you know Jonah Jang problem
um so by compiling this expression what
I mean is that it would take this
expression and then possibly do
optimizations like we discussed you will
turn actually that into 22 plus X and
then spit out the original instructions
Michael
so you put this job so you right so in
truffles you write Java programs that
describes how to interpret your language
and then it is your compiler for free
ok
so you may be wondering what kinds of
languages so there at the beginning of
the talkin mention how they offer set
out to build the vm that is able to deal
with different paradigms of languages so
there is JavaScript implemented Ruby
Python R&J the paper actually talks
about some of the challenges and
different techniques that they used to
interpret each of those languages a
highly recommended the sections of our
short we could also discuss it
afterwards if you're curious so now
let's talk about everything used all the
useful links that you might care about
if you're excited about this so thursday
grill on openjdk so it's part of OpenJDK
effort now and you can find all the link
is for the truffle api for gray area
there is a truffle Ruby effort and and
there's actually very interesting post
about how they made Ruby work on traffic
rayong platform there is a fast or so if
fast interpretation of art city which is
an implementation of Python on chopper
ground and there is joyful song so song
is restricted subset of small talk that
is
is I think primarily by research
communities you developed if to do
research on vm design and vm
technologies so it's very interesting
there's a lot of work being done a
continuum the authors continue to do
work so this is consistent modularity
you can find them slides don't worry
about recording this links i'll post the
site online so you can get a system so
for system Angela it's actually
interesting in that they were able to
scare up a team from one person working
on this project to give to people
working on Carla and different parts of
the project and some of the examples of
modularity ball they took the grave via
and what grill p.m. could target
different architectures but you could
target different host runtimes host the
end so expanding into all those
dimensions I think they are watching it
soon or they also launched it the
website it's all the things truffle and
rail so all the research there's
currently going all the papers are being
published one place which is really a
mentor and actually this small-time
implementation in truffle rail is the
fastest now and you can read about it
how it compares to other implementations
there's also being significant process
progress down on our Python Ruby and
small talk
are there any questions about this so
far yeah so I guess maybe a very naked
question so what is it what is the core
innovation is it that the ability to
describe these transformations on a hd's
that are kind of language agnostic so
that's that's that's the day yeah yeah
are you familiar with a pipeline by any
chance or I find son okay so it's a
similar idea right so pi PI is the Grail
vm equivalent and our Python is their
truffle at the equivalent the difference
between them is that pie pie pie and our
Python all the trace give you the
tracing to it whereas this gives you a
st jet calculation so and it's more
powerful because you're operating on a
higher level so you can infer a lot more
things from the semantics of it and do
many more optimizations because now you
can do glow after mrs. on the whole tree
as opposed to just under particular
trees yeah
I
I'm sure I mean um art python is a
subset of esters the subset of Python in
which you describe how to implement your
language perhaps we noticed somebody's
monologue to go that I am I haven't
played with it at all but the main
difference is that the trace teach it
versus asta so is anyone familiar is
everybody familiar with what tracing
Jets are ok ok so basically what you
define as you define entry points and
exit points from jay from traces and
traces are just a sequence of
instructions that runs one after another
so if you had some sort of control flow
like this
just have a bunch of notes this would be
one phrase so you could execute them you
could speculate that this is what you
can speculate did you always take this
path because of what you saw and then
you'll just compile the whole trace
suppose we supposed two representatives
additional branches I guess so they
they're branching off is the conditional
branches and these following is just
consecutive its instructions okay yeah
yeah sure you said that you using
trouble you describe how to interpret
your language so i think that means it's
like there's an API for like giving
semantics to your language is that like
with truffled oh so you would define
semantics right so with no special
edition for instance you would you find
that the addition guys how that should
be executed how to specialize a hedge
knight rook you're actually writing
execute methods I like dynamic
subclasses extreme so you're hearing one
thing like a virtual dispatch table and
then we're defining a budget or
specializations it's analyzing your
classes and it's building dispatch
tables and stuff on that so you're
actually writing an interpreter that's
an ASTM proof so there's like a dynamic
value type or something everything's I
out there spreading poison and whose
return expression yeah but so let you
write execute the office right XG end
and you'll say XG int is version execute
line bill my return type is int and so
you say I can execute object I switch
and then you say well if I know my
return type is int that I can bypass the
call to execute and just go directly to
execute pink which means that the caller
has to know we go to execute indirectly
so so you're writing and interpreter and
then it's a framework as takes an
interpreter and money shots parts of it
out for you exactly why are you if you
can specialize
arguments you can specialize on more or
less anything but you may have to
specialize in specialized you reduce it
so internally everything is objects or
objects of particular types that you
interested and you interested in
dispatching on particular types
particular prototypes you could express
all that using truffle API so for
JavaScript friends and then define this
notion of shapes because it's
prototypical base so if something
implements business prototype then it
requires a particular shape and then you
make an assumption that everything that
is a particular shape can be executed
using exact same function okay is that
more okay okay question is probably
coming from the naive corner of things
but would this be useful for designing a
function
it seems very object so good question
right it's actually something they're
very much interested in and I will talk
about in a moment about the work they do
to enable compiler to neighbor
expressing functional languages using
this framework the subscriber similar to
scholars of limitation it is okay yeah
it's how you look very little
acknowledgement so that fast are these
are examples
um
so um it's called Nashville
okay so in your language as an impact
over in Java I guess you're kind of is
it true that you're kind of bound to the
Java VM that you're working on
understanding of things like garbage
collection right so I guess my question
is I want to implement my own language
can I and I want to use truffle can I do
this and also implement my own garbage
collector or do I have to use whatever
growl provides a garbage collector so a
very good question so what you can do is
you can just use just the trouble if the
eye and gives a medium that you want now
the advantage of that is that you can
you don't have to use crowd right it
isn't much of that is that growl vm
speaks truffle API so you won't be able
to leverage the potential that it has
because other themes would not
understand the chocolaty I would not
know how to optimize it but then you get
your freedom from Grove via the other
thing is that they are doing research
into making a lot of parts of the system
swappable modular so who knows maybe
that's also something that they will
implement where you can just plug in
your garbage collector play with it
inside the griot via so
this program is running you can be
pistol to the GC of the g and the ground
yeah so you still have the opportunity
to serve under programs and see what
they are working profiles or I mean I
could see that being if you're
interested in or any further there's
some tighter interaction between the
garbage collector and the semantics of
the program that have to be
the arsenio isolated stacks
I think they're zombies
ideally you would never happen to me
okay yeah
you have
you also have like state
okay like does it sort of keep
everything in memory like in the most
general type and then
like if I have for example like if I
have some very bold right like I went
through some code pad and I know it's a
hint right like but now i'm not in a is
Stan more like that is like in the
memory location like eventually I like
glowed that again that somewhere like
does that you know like
how does that ok sir so so when you're
interpreting when you haven't compiled
in yet right and you probably that's
when you don't know what youre types are
in yet great it would do the checks of
types right it would figure out what to
specialize on if it can so now I'm not
quite sure what you mean by having them
in memory not knowing about JavaScript
so here's them down they have a global
variable right and like in JavaScript
like I could imagine where you know
everything is you know a JavaScript
object which is very general which is
not occupy zabal but like that maybe you
know the AST like I put this thing in
here nasty
like you know the HD compile code it's
an int like and then I could like make
this path like into specialized I think
the dead like once I write that back to
like some variable I don't really know
what type that variable is necessarily
right because then that's not talking
about the ast but it's not like the
actual object graph okay so when you
specialize on the node you also know
what the return type is for you know
right so like when you decide that
you're operating on two integers you
will swap out the head and specialized
and the return type who also be integer
and that's also something you define
with the truffle with yet but the return
type will be
as the interpreter is interpreted
exactly but the specialization is all
your responsibility
so the the trouble API has like a frame
object that represents JDM snap rings
and so it physically is it basically
assuming you're going to use a GP and
white vm representation and so what
happens when you when you program your
current program against this framing TI
and the trouble engine knows how to look
at your code and see when you're reading
it right into those types and
specialized that particular architecture
you're operating on and so when you read
or write to a mutable array that's part
of frame object it goes oh that's
actually stack frame and so it can
actually in line all that specialized
all that trip to your CPU architecture
and even though it looks like you're
dealing with like a JVM object that
represents some beautiful scattering in
reality that's going to just get all
eliminated by the framework and the
result will be like Barret loads and
stores from set similar mechanisms but
but this thing I use that you're
operating a virtualization of the
garbage collector is the heat this back
allocator but you're you have an API as
part of trouble that represents the
concepts in
that the truffle engine knows how to
eliminate and that's that's you look at
the pie pasta talked about virtualizer
bowls and something else that's the same
idea so you have an object that does not
actually exist after population but the
code in are actually all so simple those
are just ordinate job
Grill has
so the also for local variables as
Brandon mansion with brains so you want
local variables to be access to that so
we have access right so first they
represented in array of local variables
and then as a figure zagreb pattern of
usage and access what it will do is
actually drink that a way to escape
analysis to figure out what the access
our and then it doesn't go beyond this
function scope or something and then
it's going to convert that into normal
variables into normal local variable
accesses and then suppose that i decided
that it's speculated wrong on that it's
a local variable or on the shape of the
object then it has a way to reconstruct
the same frame back to d optimized in
greektown a store some metadata to
figure out what the last vlad and put
all the local variables back into one
array and
in pipe i wear a peck on you can
function vocals which is digital
dictionary and local variables and as
you can imagine this is slow so if you
are using high tide and you call locals
right it's even more slow because you
have everything written compile inside
Oh actually now this person wants to
pretend that they had an interpreter and
so it has to do is ask like look through
your stack and like undo the work it did
to speed you up and then push that into
a map whereas a big traditional C Python
interpreter just given point in the
current locals collection so so you have
this risk that you operate on the
virtual version of what the vm is doing
there's this risk that are escapes what
you actually are worse off than after it
started as an interpreter as soon so the
API they exposed to use one that
discourages you believe there is 30
feedback I'm not understand showed me
what what so I say okay so she does
yeah any feedback for which we
so I can get out xscape analysis
ask that back so it does have all right
so it does have the guards in the code
so when it generates the code for the
interpreter it make it generates the
code to make sure the desktop shins are
valid before jumping into it and then
that's how it knows how to optimize okay
so you triage features are being added
to truffle one of them is unstacked
replacement problems um imagine example
where you have a really long running
look and it's only ever executed once
well what normally would do is it would
see that the loop is being executed many
times and it would decide that and we'll
compare it and it could pause it but the
loop is on the average ticket at once so
this compilation never gets used because
it gets compounded after the loop has
finished so now with all stock
replacement it solves the problem where
the loop is running and now it figures
out that the loop has been running very
frequently and it swaps out immediately
for the compiled code so the loop
continues running on the next iteration
in front power mode so that's pretty
cool another in optimization there
another feature there is support for
telcos which is especially for questions
for functional languages of course very
exciting yeah yeah I may not get there
with you but anyway sorry so gravia of
binaries are available here remember
that thing we were discussing how your
new they have to use chromium well if
you want to use real vm you can actually
use it to execute your java binaries for
anything if they have been working on
improving performance for it and they've
seen that it's faster on some work
clothes so I thought of that I promised
some Twitter that all say something the
exact assurance I haven't forgotten that
the author is actually very interested
in closure implementation on top of
truffle grill and they believe that they
will be able to support the outpost and
they'll be very happy to support the
efforts on implementing open source
truffle closure with that I'm going to
open up the floor for more questions if
you have any yeah I needed also the
papers awesome obviously it's a great
technique I was a little bit saddened
that there was no experimental results
presented so for instance even breaking
down the time-space elevation so for
instance i cooperated paper in cgo 2010
where we did this sort of a type
specialization on a graph of the program
for the luo language we found like a 2x
improvement over like me to interpret
our speed oh so it would be awesome if
if the authors like presented and Apollo
papers from experimental results yeah I
will check have actually the growl a vm
org they may have papers i'm not quite
sure they have a lot of papers there but
um yeah they may have more following
work describing front
other questions who's excited now yeah
but i'm not familiar with how closures
like compiled over it now like how it is
different from how close your work okay
so closure right now is implemented in
Java and there's an effort being made by
the community to have closure and
closure compiler so logically would
strap closure yeah so so who's now
excited to implement their own language
and truffle mmm all right I think they
were some local publishes yeah go ahead
yeah there was so much different people
all the work yeah yeah all right okay so
let's talk about that so so why no more
if you follow morphic metamorphic right
mono Morgan was polymorphic q mugging
with mega morphic mini ok so now it went
in specifically littie well suppose
you're suppose you're in a language with
protocols
and you have a particle pedicle phone
I'll call an iphone4 interface that's
like a more closure thing okay so now we
have a implements iphone and we have
same with the implements iphone ok so
now for has a function in it just one
function say bar and now a provides an
implementation of war and they provides
an implementation of bar now when we
have an object an instance of what a
base see we have an X we need to figure
out which of the functions we're
actually which of the implementation was
actually going to invoke great so what
we're going to do is we're going to
provide we're going to check always 8x
instance of a or is accent set up p and
then if x the sentence of a then we're
going to invoke eight implementation in
other words we're going to info piece
implementation so it's not really cash
in the classical sense x somewhere in
memory value store it's more it's in the
code i usually as part of the
instructions and it just figures out
which of the implementation in state box
so that's what polymorphic in like
mm yeah exactly like in line parties
like it being just integrating the code
I think the Khalsa sorry does it be they
the call site Nicole said yeah yeah okay
yeah um i guess i have to kind of
speculative questions questions so the
goal here or at least one my goal here
is to have a vm that is capable of
implementing many different varieties of
languages on top of it and i guess i
have questions about two families of
languages and whether they would be
reasonable to try to implement on top of
truffle and grow the first is so you're
asking interpreter takes this frame
object that somehow lets you store local
variables um what if i was implementing
a language that doesn't have local
variables like a stack-based language
like fourth or a factor would that be
possible would it be reasonable would
you still get the same ability to
optimize that you get good question so
for staff based languages my guess and
feel free to jump in and suggest there
this is that you can you could leverage
they frame objects inside it to access
the variables and manipulate them now
for other things actually not sure does
anybody have any
so what makes you so choose a
stack-based like that led to changes
right to people so what you can imagine
is if you if you have this dysfunction
right that when you're compiling it you
can figure out our am i popping things
off of the stack that I expect from
somewhere else in which case that's like
a global and am i popping things that I
can tribute prove I just pushed on to
the stack in which case is like a level
so you can end up with this with you
know so a stack-based language although
semental II a stack-based doesn't
actually end up that way just like you
know when you write you know Java it's
all its semantically everything is the
heap but actually it moves things on the
stack when it feels like it and you know
in the runtime intends to take liberties
to make it go faster but like I would
have to do that kind of figuring out
where my stack based indices turn into
local variables myself and my
orientation I don't think truffle would
do that for me is that right right yeah
I mean if you are in a flea where you're
just like here is one giant list i'm
going to only push up on that and Trump
was not gonna be able to do I mean
you'll get the standard you know
musicians that cover in the JVM can try
but you know if you want to make it
better just just as everything with
truffle grill it is you have to figure
out how to make that and it'll make it
go faster for you yeah i mean i don't i
don't know i'm not totally familiar with
like call stack sort of like what
provides our head bobbing and whatnot
but i kind of defining characteristic of
like a fourth or a factor is that to sex
at least separating data and and and
call that a calls and so and so the
interesting thing is is that you get a
call stack somewhat for free in your ast
if your language doesn't actually have
function calls at all right which is
actually totally possible all right you
just align everything just insert it if
you've never actually like put a main
call franklin stack you're still going
to get the optimizations from the way
the AST works and your interpreter is
still going to have call frames and when
you call execute on the sub node or
otherwise related note and so the frame
is about data on the stack and so
I don't know specifically the answer of
what a TI looks like but I know that
that the interesting thing about Stan
language is that they separate the data
stack and the call stack and the frame
object that's in that's it truffle is
got an array for the data and then it's
a linked list a sec you need the call
stack and so you can work with them
independently meeting with some trigger
so this is a core question though this
goes to the core of the paper what's
interesting about it lots of different
languages that
against many different VMs it's not
surprising it's not that innovative
what's innovative about this is it's
giving you a strategy for implementing a
language against a vm so you don't have
to go to the ER line wrong time or the
JVM or something else and say what he'll
do I do now you have the API which gives
you an approach to take so if it doesn't
handle static images I'm sure they're
very interested in that insight and
they'd love to add capabilities to
support couples I think we've been more
than that we provides an opportunity to
target a highly optimized p.m. which you
never have as language designer it takes
decade over a decade to document it so
you have access to that and the second
thing is when you agree with what you
said it focuses you on the ast run the
byte codes which as I salute said is a
high level reputation and it's easier to
write that stuff all right what doesn't
ever can go to the more abstract as you
become as your tools become more cables
I mean lvm might be a counter example of
that because they optimized on SSI
Beckham okay well it'd be two different
approaches them so mr. Bernstein can
talk about the anti approach the bike
coker setia stupid actually truffle of
real authors the way they convert them
so steelo vm is that they're high-level
virtual machine versus low low in verse
for sure if any of you to actually try
targeting all yeah there's a lot of
mind-bending you have to do to make a
language target along vm and then it
does all this wonderful things if only
you actually get through the pains of
making it be representin l
and one other thing is that if you're
viewing specialization partial
evaluation in lying all that sort of
stuff you can actually have multiple
different V ends right so if you have a
minimum instructions of mineral
instructions in so say you're the staff
language we're doing a small list you've
got eight or nine primitives right your
interpreter for your eight or nine
primitives they have an interpreter for
the JVM bytecode and so what happens is
you have a bottom to the language you
can just add whatever other nodes you
want an AST whatever makes whatever
optimization convenient so what's
actually happening is that it's going to
special you're going to write
specializations for your language
primitives and then you're going to
write compilation to some other set of
AST nodes that somebody else is an
average specializations for and so if
what your goal is and so what's gonna
happen is if you produce in a
compilation step JVM bytecode it's
actually going to execute abstractly
partially evaluate the JVM bytecode
before that ultimately comes machine and
so there are many many levels and what
this does is because you have some type
expression that has some method execute
that's virtual you have ultimately
extensible set of things that I know how
to interpret in terms of other things I
know how to interpret and ultimately
you're going to keep expanding until you
hit x86 and block and so you can you can
actually get right through three
different languages so actually the
later parts of paper actually explain if
you can't actually do that
you have to fight everything up ahead oh
really yeah thatthat's there's there's
another thing that this paper doesn't go
into that you can look up later but if
you if you look the real research hope I
did I'm operating assets from the
scholar gasps there's does that yeah so
basically you can't um in many cases you
don't end up with a full Judy I'm after
all this is done okay interesting good
did you have a question what if we don't
end up with a full JDM after all this is
done for optimizing away talk to the JVM
yeah there's actually there's there's a
companion there's a third companion
technology that actually optimizes the
way the JVM and gives you this like this
curl down yeah strip is the compelling
use case is like you know man the JVM is
really fast and man I really wish this
in this job the shelter was faster than
node but the JPM takes five seconds
start up when I look like crap so many
photos make it fast like what do I do
and so there's a third thing called
substrate and such
so that you can have like two
milliseconds to get your JavaScript p.m.
but in doing so you give up the JVM past
see what you know there's a concluding
yeah you must open a coke living and all
the like a lot of the flexibility did
you have two questions how's my next
question was okay so the answer for
snack languages was like maybe probably
what about logic programming languages
they did prolong it did I did problem
it's almost a source August answers yes
okay any other questions comments not a
question but um somebody brought up llvm
before which is really interesting
technology to something we're pointing
out here is that truffle is doing some
things that you cannot do in llvm that
are really attractive for dynamic
languages llvm doesn't give you enough
access to to what it's generating to do
a self-modifying code or code rewrite it
whereas truffle can actually modify your
code and do on stack replacement and
specialized things at runtime which
would be either impossible or very very
difficult
well Cassie truck built on top of my
life does anybody worried about the
monoculture of like L name is the best
and JDM is the best and like nobody will
ever investigate alternatives I hear a
lot of that yellow yeah can you travel
for geostain you know it looks like a
monoculture but I mean if you think
about it you know there's there's
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
engineering time is important to this
stuff like GCC has been around for
longer and they even have sometimes
companies move back at you know they
even put like five over ten engineers
but they don't have I'm like you
know son Oracle like being like okay
here's like 500 guys like you good you
just you know go ahead and make this up
really awesome and you know so like so
yeah IBM put more into some of the JV
and stuff that subject and they can send
lots of big companies of it right
there's a whole piece so it is a lot of
culture but
change your mind really like if you
design your language like for this
environment right selecting the closure
and it's like you know what this sucks
we really can't get alcohols everywhere
but if we just don't extend library that
assumes Cal cause everywhere we add a
couple little things to our language to
like deal with the fact that run times
are constrained if you haven't learned
lessons of the fine 70s then you know
like you you can still innovate even
though you have a swap out your back in
it's like well closure ramaiya fix big
leap forward in many areas for the
designs of functional and dynamic and
lists and whatever and now we'll come
along and say okay we have a different
back in technology and now we get
alcohol your look great that's welcome
question so the thing is that the reason
everyone forgets all games may be able
to implement them again they're right in
the ass control level stuff and so the
only time you ever see something like
that is when there's enough effort
because the existing technologies don't
support of on you co a vm because jamie
and would support these super
high-performance eric languages that you
really want to deal with and then you
see like v8 and
all of the monkey technologies and all
these things show up because JDM is
terrible for dealing with super-high
like low latency star enemy them a lot
of these in the three at once and you
don't want to deal with all JDM overhead
let's other feel out there a lot of vm
is popping up you see Dropbox starting
their own in Python procedure based
thing that's different than the ast and
different than at racing game because
they decided that it isn't quite what
they want so it's less than issue of my
culture and more people just don't
want to implement their own VMs
they want to international mall so so
you said monoculture but then he said
note so I know he went well so there
ought to the ends up there but there are
only a few on few games that have lots
and lots of work put behind them right
video games was not his partner will say
it is like you mentioned factor factor
was like what seven or eight primary
contributors and there they be g eight
on a lot of a lot of benchmarks granting
v8 solving a harder problem making
JavaScript ass like it's not like if
doable I didn't know how I am just not
that much fun so what's wrong if you
wanna culture the thing is that it's
open source now you know ten years ago
which was
culture you couldn't touch it but now
you can actually go and do things if you
want to and make small changes and
that's fantastic the problem with mono
culture is like a competition is so
awesome is industry packing if there's a
company backing it well they can start
resting on their laurels right like I
mean spider monkey was not very fast
until the it came along like I love how
you need ways and competitions imma
start for being a bold open source but
i'm really at the same time when you
look at like all the killer beams like
you look at hot spot dark and NV 8 it's
the same group of people if you want a
new vm then the key is there is there
are 10 people of the whole planet who
can help you do this and all you need to
do is hire two or three of them it is a
potential it is a potential dart into
the heart of that Arnold culture in a
way where like that this is actual
innovation and the idea that you can
modular leedy couple the front end from
the back end this way is really
interesting and the other thing is that
you know you don't like this I mean how
long is this working on 14 he wasn't
yeah you know that if you know we are
getting we are getting faster and better
at building games and I think that this
also just this also is a you know a
death knell to the monoculture in the
way that it is a it is a language
toolkit that is not designed to optimize
a specific kind of language necessarily
right so if it does work better on
certain kinds of languages but they're
open to advance to orbiting that and
you're working on other kinds of
languages where as before if you've seen
the closure compiler there's all kinds
of machinations in there to make a list
fast on top of something that doesn't
assume certain things that you need to
make lists fast so I think that's a fair
statement and I think that this really
interesting work to see like that to
couple there's like you know it will get
people get faster move in general did
you come point point they made is key
like that that's what I wasn't seeing oh
my God we're just building on top of the
GBM but since we have this separation
where you write your interpreter in a
higher level and then you have a
back-end swappable yeah and then the
trade-offs the trade of the ability to
like to optimize the way that JVM and
make a trade off between later
optimizations and faster startup times
for example it's something that we have
never had the opportunity to do before
so I think it's pretty it was
fascinating work awesome presentation
another advantage of actually having all
these different language to be
implemented
framework is that how every single
language implements especially in the
same paradigms influence exact same
additional no exact same way spamming we
could share the code if javascript
handles or Python or Ruby handle
addition multiplication out similar like
why I duplicate the code we could just
reuse all that or if you're in the same
paradigm you could reuse a lot of
include specific implementations of
interpreters which is I think it's
really really cool because now we open
up to a lot of the different languages
sharing a lot of the code really working
much easier so let's say you had a
JavaScript interpreter there was a
hundred percent faithful and implemented
although beard edge cases and then
you're like how much password could I
make it if I stripped all those out you
can just do that at the high level and
not worry about I was out affect the
three levels of optimizing compiler may
be pretty interesting yeah definitely
all right what to conclude there is some
awesome Scotch courtesy of the reversal
of organizers that I would like to share
with you
keep talking about virtual machines and
compilers and languages thank you for
coming